(upbeat music)
- It's all about solving problems.
It's not about, like
maybe in previous years
you've done multiplication
table memorization.
It's not like memorizing
how to solve problems.
It's learning the tools
of how to solve problems
and then using them and building
them up in creative ways.
So it really does remind me of art
because if you are doing
a painting or something,
you have specific tools
about maybe paint brushes
or different techniques you can use
to create something bigger.
So I feel like algebra is really
all about combining things
that you already know how
to do into something bigger.
- So the word algebra comes
from the Arabic word algebra
that literally translates
to reunion of broken parts.
This is breaking apart of
mathematical representations
and putting it back together
in the form of balanced equations
is the essence of algebra.
And the beautiful thing
is that this balancing
and solving of equations can
be done in many different ways
which is where creativity comes in.